a man takes a young boy and his
babysitter hostage
after sawing through a wall all during a
barricade situation in the south valley
thanks for joining us at 11 o'clock i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
everyone is now safe
and that suspect is in custody but that
barricade lasted for more than 24 hours
orco mana has more on this story
it's definitely crazy about where it was
especially when it's
close to home a chaotic couple days at
this las vegas motel
metro police say a hispanic man tried to
take off on a stolen motorcycle
after a patrol officer noticed a couple
stolen vehicles here
wednesday morning they got into a fight
but the officer backed down when he saw
the man reach for a gun
the suspect barricaded himself inside a
motel room and shot at officers
police say the suspect then used a
hammer and saw to cut through a wall
and took a four-year-old boy and his
babysitter hostage
swat and crisis negotiators were able to
get the boy released wednesday night
that was shocking and obviously
emotional to know a child was being put
through that
the bar manager next door telling us
police briefly brought the boy here
it's just traumatizing i know it's like
even in your parking lot
negotiators worked for hours convincing
the suspect to let the babysitter go
thursday afternoon
the suspect eventually surrendered and
no one was injured
this is the kind of thing that the lvmpd
swat team and negotiators train for
and prepare for and there's nothing more
important to us than the sanctity of
life
we use all of the negotiation tactics
available to us
to bring this to a peaceful resolution a
sigh of relief
after a scary situation i'm just happy
that everyone all the hostages made it
out alive and
they weren't hurt